དེ་ཉར་ཨ
ག་རེ་ལབ་སོང་།
ད་བསད་སོང་ད།
སྣུམ་མང་པོ་བླུགས་ནས་བསད་སོང་ང་ད། ད་འགུལ་སྤྱོད་གཏོང་༼ཡ་༽མི་འདུག
ད་འགུལ་སྤྱོད་བཏང་༼ཡ་༽མི་འདུག་ག
ཚང་མ་ཤི་སོང་ད།
འདི། ཚང་མ་ཤི་སོང་ད། ད་དེའི་ནང་ལ་གཅིག་འདུག
དེའི་ནང་ལ་ག་རེ་བཟོས་ཡོད་རེད།
འདི་མི་ཆེན་པོ་གིས་རྩེ་༼ཡ་༽རེད།
ད་ཚར་སོང་ད།
དེ་ཤུགས་ཆེ་དྲག
ད་དེ་སྟོན་ད། སྟོན་ད།
དེ་ག་རེ་བླུགས་རེད།
ད་ཚང་མ་བཟོས་༼ཞག༽་སོང་།
ག་རེ་བྱས་མ་སོང་།
ག་རེ་བྱས་སོང་།
བྱ་དེ།
གཤོག་པ་གཉིས་འདུག་ག་བྱ་དེ་དེ་ལ།
བྱ་དེ་སྟོན་དགོས།
དེ་ནང་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།ཆུང་ཆུང་ནང་དེ་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།བྱ་དེ་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།
བལྟ་ཨ།
དེ། ང་རང་འདི། དེ་མ་རེད་(ད)་འདི།
གཉིས་ཆ་༼ཁ་གྱི་༽གཅིག་པ་རེད། ད་མར་ཉལ་དགོས།
གཤོག་པ་དེ་ཚོལ་༼ཡ་༽རེད་བས།
ཁོ་གཉིས་གཉིས་སུ་རེད་མིང་དེ།
ཁོང་གཉིས་གཉིས་ག་རེ་ལབ་སོང་། ༼རྨོར་ཏོ་༽རེད་འདུག་ག
མེ་རྫོགས་རེད། མེ་རྫོགས་རེད་བས།
ད་(ར)། ཨི་་རྐང་པ་གཏུབ་སོང་།
ག་རེ། ཟ་༼ཡ་༽རེད་༼ཞག༽
དེ་རིང་ག་རེ་བྱེད་༼ཡ་༽རེད།
དེ་ལྟ་ཚར་རེད་(ར)།
ད་དུང་གཅིག་ལྟ་༼ཡ་༽རེད་བས།
སྡིག་པ་རྭ་ཙ་རེད་བས།
སྡིག་པ་རྭ་ཙ་ག་བ་འགྲོ་སོང་ད། ད་གིན་ལྟ་༼འཇོག་༽རེད་(བ)།
ལྟད་མོ་ལྟ་༼ཡ་༽དེ་ག་བ་འགྲོ་སོང་།
དང་པོ་དེ་ལྟ་དགོས། མ་རེད། སྡིག་པ་རྭ་ཙ་ཕ་གིར་འདུག་ག འདི།
སྡིག་པ་རྭ་ཙ། ང་འདི་་
མ་བྱེད་ད།
ག་རེ་ལབ་སོང་།
གཅིན་པ་ཟ་ལབ་ལབ་སོང་།
ཁོས་ཁ་ལག་Khawoལབ་སོང་ང་། སི་ལི་པི་ལབ་སོང་ང་།
སྒོ་ང་།
ག་རེ་བྱེད་༼ཡ་༽རེད་(ད)།
མ་བྱེད་ད། ད་ལྟ་བྱེད་དགོས་འདུག་(ད)། འདི་༼ཨ་ནས་༽འདི་བྱེད་༼ཡ་༽རེད།
འདི་ལ་ཡོད་ས་རེད།
ཁྱེད་རང་པུ་གུ་བྱེད་གས། ཨ།
ང་ལ་འདི་དགོས།
འདི་ག་འདྲས་བྱེད་དགོས་རེད། མར་གཡུག་གི་ཡིན་ད།
འདི་ལག་པ་སུ་གི
ག་རེ་བྱེད་༼གི་༽ཡིན། ང་ལ་མ་ལབ་ཨ།
ང་བྱས་མེད་ད།
ཨེ་་གློག་འབར་སོང་།
སྔོན་ནས་འབར་འདུག་ག
ད་དུང་གློག་༼སྤར་༽འདུག་ག
ད་གིན་(ར)། གློག་༼སྤར་༽སོང་ང་། ཐག་ཐག་ལབ་སོང་ང་།
ལྟ་ཨ། ད་ལྟ་དེ་གློག་༼སྤར་༽གི་རེད་(ད)།ལྟ་ཨ།
གློག་ལག་པ་༼གི་༽མི་འདུག ད་ངེད་གཉིས་ཚོང་པ་བྱེད་དགོས། ཚོང་པ།
ད་དེ་ཁྱེད་རང་མི་བྱེད་༼ཡ་༽རེད་(ད)།དེ་ཁྱེད་རང་བྱེད་༼ཡ་༽རེད་(ད)་(ལོ)།
དེ་ཁྱེད་རང་བྱེད་༼ཡ་༽རེད་(ད)་(ལོ)། དེ་ཁྱེད་རང་བྱེད་༼ཡ་༽རེད་(ད)་ལབ་ཡིན།
དེ་ཁྱེད་རང་བྱེད་༼ཡ་༽རེད་(ད)་ལབ་ཡིན།
དེ་ཁྱེད་རང་མིང་བྲིས་ཨ།
ང་ལ་བཞག་ས་རག་སོང་། ང་ལ་བཞག་ས་རག་སོང་། ཁྱེད་རང་ལ་བཞག་ས་རག་སོང་ངས།
ཁྱེད་རང་ལ་བཞག་ས་རག་སོང་ང་འདི་ལ། ལྟ་ད། ལྟ་ད་བྱས་བཞག་ས་རག་སོང་ང་།
ང་རང་གིས་གཅིག་བཟོ་དགོས་(ལོ)།
དབུགས་མ་འཐེན་ཨ། ཁྱེད་རང་དབུགས་བཏང་ད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽། ང་གཅིག་ལབ་དགོས། སྨྱུ་གུ་སྤྲད་ད། སྨྱུ་གུ་སྤྲད་ད་ངས་མཐོང་མ་སོང་སྨྱ་གུ་
སྨྱུ་གུ་མཐོང་མ་སོང་། སྨྱུ་གུ  སྨྱུ་གུ་ང་ལ་སྤྲད་མ་སོང་།
གཙང་མ་བཟོ་༼ཡ་༽ཕ་གིར་འདུག་ག
འདི།
འདི་ལ་བསྡད་ཤི། འདི་ལ་བསྡད།
མི་དགོས།
ང་རང་ང་རང་ང་ཁ་གྱི།
ཕ་གི
ཡོང་ག མི་དགོས།
པུ་གུ་ག་བ། སྤུ་གུ
མཚོན་ཁྲ་སྨྱུ་གུ་ག་བར། ཨ་་མཚོན་ཁྲ་སྨྱུ་གུ
མཚོན་ཁྲ་སྨྱུ་གུ་གཉིས་རག་སོང་ང་ལ།
ང་རའི་ཅ་ལག འདི་ང་རའི་ཅ་ལག་རེད། ཁྱེད་རང་ཅ་ལག་མ་རེད།
ང་རང་ཅ་ལག་༼ཁེར་༽ཤོག
མ་བཏང་།
ང་ང་རའི་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་༼ཡ་༽རེད་(ད)།ཁྱེད་རང་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་༼ཡ་༽མ་རེད་(ད)།
ང་ཁ་གྱི། ཨ་ཕ་མ་རེད་(ད)།ང་རའི་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་༼ཡ་༽རེད།
ང་ལ་འདི་མི་དགོས། ཕལ་༼ཁེར་༽ད།
ང་ལ་མི་དགོས། ང་ལ་འབྲས་གཅིག་པོ་དགོས།
འབྲས་དགོས། ང་ལ་འབྲས་དགོས།
ང་ལ་འབྲས་དགོས། ང་ལ་འབྲས་དགོས།
ང་ང་ལ་འབྲས་དགོས།
ཨི། འོ་མ་འཐུང་སོང་ང་།
Baby འདི་ལ། ང་གཉིས་དང་པོ་ཡིན།
ཨ་་་གྲང་མོ་བཟོས་ད། ང་ཕུ་རྒྱག་ཐུབ་༼གི་༽མེད།
ང་ལ་འདི་དགོས། སྣབ་ཕྱི། སྣབ་ཕྱི་འདི་ལ་ཡོད།
སྤྲད་ད། ང་བྱེད་དགོས།
གཙང་མ་བཟོས་ཡིན།
མ་རེད། གཞས་འདིའི་ནང་ལ།
ཕུར་གཏང་ནས་ང་གཞས་འཁྲབ་༼གི་༽ཡིན།
དེ་ཕལ་བཞག་ད། ང་གཞས་འཁྲབ། དེ་མར་རིལ་གི་རེད་(ད)་དེ་ཚོ།
ང་ཨ་ཕ་རོགས་པ་བྱེད་དགོས།
ང་ང་རའི་ཨ་་།
འདི་ལ་ཕོར་པ་གཅིག་འདུག